Now let's come up with some
concrete equations for derivatives.
For instance, if this equation describes
the dependence of my position on time,
the position should be (t + 1)³.
Actually, we are ignoring physical
units of measurement right now.
What would the rate of change be?
Let's magnify a portion of that curve.
It's saying this is some time t,
and this is, a little later, t + h.
Throughout this course, h will denote
a small increment of time.
Then the x value here
is (t + 1)³,
and the x value here
is (t + h + 1)³.
And the question now is
what the rate of change is.
What you're interested in is the ratio
of the gain in x to the timestep that we're making.
This side obviously has a length of h,
and this side has a length of
(t + h + 1)³ - (t + 1)³.
So let's write down the ratio--
[(t + h + 1)³ - (t + 1)³]/h.
Now comes the question,
if h is really small,
what would this expression become?
Would it become t + something that
can be neglected for every tiny h?
Would it become (t + 1)² + something that we can neglect,
3t² + something that can be neglected
or 3(t + 1)² + something we can neglect?